tonight it's been you know I took a long
break off of weed and mushrooms um and
so tonight I thought I would take both
for this
[Applause]
show now I want to tell you guys a
couple
things these are drier than I was hoping
they were going to
be
I forgot how bad they
taste they really eating those it's like
eating a it's like licking a camel's
[__] um
but I figured we're in Austin we like to
get a little weird here in
Austin I've been I also
like I I it's been so long since since
I've been high on stage we'll see what
happens yeah I feel fine now um okay on
the plane ride in
here I something happened to me that has
never happened before have you ever
farted yourself
awake have you done have you done that
before dude
yeah yeah dude I had never like in
public I had never done that before
and I was on the plane and those leather
seats are not
forgiving and I was just there sleeping
and it was just like I was
like and then then had dawn on me I'm
like oh that's [__]
me and so I I wanted to see if the dude
next to me
knew so I just
gave a slow
like he was staring at me
like and I said hey I'm really sorry
man and he goes not your first
one
super embarrassing you know he wouldn't
let me go to sleep for the rest of the
plane ride by the way every time I'd KN
off he'd go
uh-uh uh so here's what we've been doing
um we've been doing like and by the way
I'm super
high you want to know something you are
too me too yeah yeah not not as high as
him that's for [__] sure can I can I
tell you guys something by the way
people ask if we get high together we
don't get high together but we've been
high in the same spot a
lot example a yeah right now
yeah keep keep going you were talking my
turn my turn yeah yeah is it my turn is
it my turn should I take the
reins this is not a [__] Carry
Underwood song dude I got
it yes yes did you actually take
mushrooms earlier or was this for C
value are you talking about in my high
on mushrooms right now
yeah he's definitely very high on
mushrooms yeah yeah now I didn't take no
Heroes dose you know what I mean but I'm
definitely High yeah I warned you hey by
the way you know want I feel pretty good
that you don't know that I'm
hot How am I'm doing better than I
thought I
was hey don't start going down by the
way I feel so much better about that
story I just told the whole time I was
like can tell I'm so
high everybody's looking at me right now
they can tell I'm so
high yeah man yeah do you really want to
be like your dad the com
medium he said that like you he said
that like it was a bad thing
um
uh well I would say he actually doesn't
want to do what I'm doing correct I
think he's better than you dude I I'll
tell you something right now first of
all all I hope he's better than me
second of
all second of all I like his mustache
more than
yours so eat that dick you know what I'm
saying boy naed it oh yeah he did he's
super funny he's super funny yeah yeah
can you play the guitar yes can I play
the guitar yeah I'll play as some guitar
okay um
okay he is uh let's go over the he
Everybody by the way my oldest son
Trevor is here
tonight uh he
is where is he he's in the
back yeah this guy right here
hey what's that how many kids you have
Christ they
all none of your [__] business how
many kids I have and by the way is two
that many dude you seem [__] where do
you live Utah you have two kids what the
[__] bro they're just popping out like
weeds all over the place one two that's
it two [__] whoa how many more you
got back there numb that's two kids I
can't believe how many that
is they look at your brothers man I I'm
I'm sorry dude your heckling is not
getting any better you're just screaming
facts the Heckler that screams facts is
the best character ever you should be on
SNL like your shirt is bigger than it
should
[Laughter]
be odly specific
Hackle I'm sorry I'm still talking hey
uh so most of you probably don't know
this that he has four kids I I'm a
grandfather you have four [__] Grand
kid is that what happens your grown kids
have kids is that [__] where are you
from what the [__] I would say that's
too many though yeah or's too many so so
you about came out of his chair when I
said for he was like the [__] I like
this guy
[Music]
[__] love wait wait wait I don't I
don't know what you said what did you
say I think she said yeah
right yeah
[Applause]
I that's
right I don't I
was yeah dude no we're totally okay yeah
I want to [__] a professional
comedian you're not listen at this point
I definitely don't feel like a
professional
comedian and at this point I don't think
it's a fight um
so so you're good all right so but um so
he so he was like you can pick your
grandpa name and I said
okay and so I go hey give me a
day and he was smart he said come up
with
three so and I'm like okay and my and um
my cuz my wife and I were both like
hey if someone calls me Grandpa at the
park I'm straight up ignoring
them like I'm not answering to anybody
calling me Gramps or paa or I I don't
know who you
are right okay okay
right
so he calls the next day and my wife had
picked her name is Bethany and you know
it's not easy to say Bethany and she was
like it'd be fun BB right great
one and he goes to me he goes what' you
come up with I said
LeBron and he said what I go dude who
doesn't want to go to BB in the bronze
house are you kidding me right now no
that is the [__] joint to be
BB in lebronze comes with a theme song
and [__] BB and LeBron it sounds like a
70 sitcom not a chance why can't my
favorite part no Trevor my favorite part
is you go to me
no and he goes and I go why not he goes
is everything a joke with you I was like
are you new
yeah did we just meet dude yeah
everything is a joke Yeah Yeah but I had
to go with
JoJo BB and
JoJo um okay that being
said do you have any questions for him
before I shoot both of them off the
stage anybody
yeah many Gramps is he on I thought you
called me Gramps I was like listen I
just told you dude wait so nobody calls
me
Gramps actually well hold on remember
how I okay so when he turned 50 or
before he turned 50 I decided I was
going
to you heard me you heard me don't act
like it's
new so before he turned 50 I was like I
think I'm going to start calling him
something different when he turns 50
just you know as a little like gut punch
every time change his name of my phone
yell at a couple times for a couple
months and then you know just slowly Let
It Fade off and I decided to call him
pops by the time he turned 50 and it's
all caps in my phone his name is just
simply pops nothing else and I warned
him because he is already like he said a
grandfather by the time he turns 60 it
will be upgraded to Gramps in my f and
there is y dude I call you and I hear on
your phone Gramps Gramps now I will
strangle the life out of you it is
unavoidable it is inevitable just know
that all right guys say hello to my
friend Jeremy Shocky everybody
you need
this okay let's just do those
four I'm pretty
hot
nice whoa that's bright and let's do the
wave first
yeah
okay
so my wife uh we were in the one day and
the weight came on by the
band and she was like man I love this
song so much and I said I can't wait to
ruin it for
you 2 3
4 when I was in high school I
masturbated every
day then my faithful
morning I look the wrong
way I look down to words
way way too
early I look down too
early
he I shot the load right on
[Music]
me when I was in high school I got my
first
PJ it made
feel so happy and
okay she said hey please warn
me before you blow please warm me before
you go please warm
me
hey she spit the load back on
me hey yo Josh you mind if I take make a
verse yeah go ahead dude all right here
we go this is fun I met a guy named
Danny back in my college
days it was until I met Danny that I
learned I swung both
way had sex with
Danny had sex with
Danny lots of sex with
Danny yeah yeah
yeah Danny had sex with
[Music]
[Applause]
me just you know these aren't true
stories this is just
songs all right all right hey um what
you want to do
next oh yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so my
wife absolutely thinks this is basically
one of the best love love songs ever
written and so I I couldn't wait to ruin
it
but basically what you need to know is I
hurt my right shoulder and I had to use
my left
[Music]
hand for a lot of things that I wasn't
accustomed
to this is my
experience
I'm still pretty
[Music]
hot I checked into my hotel room close
the door and shut the
blinds I open the laptop got out the
lotion it's time to treat myself
right and I started in up and down
motion
something was definitely
off it was real Herky jerky nothing was
working like a hand job from Michael J
fox too soon too
soon
and it ended up way more
violence when I SM
hands my dick was bruised and
battered it looked just like Chris
Brown's
[Applause]
[Music]
girlfriend too soon is that too soon for
that is that too soon
I told you that one would
work that you did all right this is you
want to do the brand brand new one yeah
yeah yeah so I have to read we
do okay so um this is like my my wife
loves
Kelly thanks you okay my wife loves k
loves yeah yeah that's exactly what
she's going to do when she hears this
song by the way the fact that there's
laughs in there are great I just every
line is I'm picturing how much she hates
it
[Music]
okay just needed a little
saliva hey man I I know we're good
friends I'll ride with you until the
end yeah yeah you know you're my
boy remember last week you were out of
town I was at the house to help your mom
out yeah yeah she needed my
help she said can you build some shell
I said I know how to do
that she said you can still help me out
dude I [__] your
mom this ain't even the first time she
likes my da yeah yeah don't be mad love
you man can we still be
friend I [__] your
mom
[Applause]
are you out of your mind you [__] my mom
and you think things are
fine yeah yeah I'm going to punch your
face I'd feel the same but here the
something else in play your mom and I
have something to say hey she's pregn
and we're in
love I'm your new
dad I know it's weird cuz we're the same
age but it'll be red yeah yeah think of
it play night BS and B
ribs cuz I'm your new
dad
Josh
Wolf hey I'm Josh Wolf and I'm Jacob
wolf and this is family tussle the
fatherson competition show where the
loser has to do an embarrassing
punishment let's go well today we are
doing it's a model competition uh rack
fieldable clothes will be put in front
of us and we will get to choose two
outfits we're going to be judged on our
style and our catwalk he's going to try
and win based on Comedy or style points
raw sex I'm I'm bubbling with t
testosterone probably not at my age you
know that little swish walk where that
leg comes in front of the other where
you have to be careful not to squish
your nuts together strategy going into
the competition flipping the hair a lot
of hips in the walk you know just some
stuff I've picked up some from a
Victoria Secret fashion show I've seen
Zoolander like 40
times get ready to kiss my heels baby
cuz this walk's going to be fierce